[Music]
hi it's Wednesday this is what I look
like when I finished mowing the lawn I
hate it I hate it so much I mean it
would be one thing if I was working hard
for something I believe in but I'm
working hard for something I hate grass
I'm so gross I have to take a shower huh
I feel much better by the way Hank the
other person who said hello to you was
nerdfighter extraordinaire Kelly Fineman
show about hey bookshelf background nice
to see you again how you guys doing
everybody's still cataloged yep yeah we
got some reference we got some general
Christianity over here down here we got
some child prodigies perfect Hank I know
that you said that I should just get rid
of all the grass on our property and it
does definitely I just said property
funny and it does bother me that we
spend all of this water and all of this
energy in order to maintain a lawn that
I only walk on when I am mowing it but
unfortunately for me the only thing that
I hate more than wasting water and
energy and time mowing the lawn is being
ostracized by my peers and I know that's
not very nerdfighteria of me but it's a
fact I just can't bear the thought of
all of the people in this neighborhood
hating me I mean they're already kind of
dubious about us so until I can gather
up some nerdfighter courage I'm gonna
keep mowing the lawn incidentally Hank
do you know what the difference is
between regular cupcakes and nerdfighter
cupcakes instead of containing a lot of
sugar nerdfighter cupcakes contain a lot
of Awesome now about the ex-girlfriends
when I did this uh none of the stuff I
was thinking was very funny so I don't
want to say but since you called me on
and I'll explain it what I was thinking
is that I spent all of these years being
really mean to my ex-girlfriends because
you know they dumped me in the manners
in which they dumped me were kind of
seemingly excessively cruel but now when
I look back on and it doesn't seem like
this dichotomy where I was good and they
were bad and I stayed with them and they
left me
it seems more like thank God I ended up
with the Yeti and maybe they've been
through enough because what I've
realized is just because you date
someone for two
1/2 years and then dump them over
Instant Messenger doesn't mean that it's
entirely your fault that the
relationship ended in fact you could
make an argument that I wasn't a great
boyfriend until I met the Yeti and now
you could make the argument that I'm not
a great husband although I did just mow
the lawn and that is one husbandly duty
ok on to another topic Hank in the last
few days there's been a lot of talk in
my pants about whether or not people
from other countries and people under
the age of 18 should be able to
contribute to Daniel bise's campaign
fund I think I tend to agree with you
that people under 18 should be allowed
to contribute and in general to
contribute more to the political process
and initially I thought I agreed with
you when you said that people from other
countries should not be allowed to you
know give money to American political
campaigns because it's not like we would
won't say the Netherlands running the
American political process but then I
realized I do want the Netherlands to
run the American political process
they're a lot better at it than we are I
mean Hank there are more murders on
American TV in a week than there are
actual murders in the Netherlands in a
year I made that statistic up but I bet
it's true but Hank who knows maybe my
optimism about the American political
experience will change specifically the
most reasonable way I think it might
change is if people elected Daniel Biss
to be the state representative in his
district in Illinois contributions to
Daniels act blue page made before
midnight Eastern Time on Friday will
count toward my punishment as well
contributions from people outside the
United States and from minors to the
fund to decrease worldsuck Hank I'll see
you tomorrow